bonsoir à tous c'était il ya un an nous
faisons la connaissance de deux élèves
de l'école thierry marx florian et rabhi
qui avait entamé une formation pour
trouver un emploi dans la boulangerie
espoir et appréhension se mêlent aussi
chez florian 22 ans marc d'enfourcher un
scooter pour livrer des pizzas le jeune
homme se rêve boulanger quand on rentre
dans une boulanger on sent l'odeur du
pain c'est vrai que ça nous met tout de
suite dans l'ambiance l'ambiance est
sympa également en arrive devant les
vitrines moi j'arrive toujours avec les
yeux grands ouverts parce que c'est vrai
que c'est super 8 semaines à l'école et
trois semaines en entreprise pour
apprendre le métier la cadence et
forcément soutenu au point parfois de se
mettre à cafouiller en calcul mental
j'ai fait les ingrédients youtube l'us
open alors attrapé
[Musique]
nous avons rendez vous chez fleuriau
bonjour et c'est un jeune homme heureux
qui nous accueille en sortant de l'école
florian à trouver du travail tout de
suite un emploi dans une boulangerie
dijonnaise tu t'attendais à ça non pas
vraiment mais c'est vrai que par rapport
à ce que nous avait dit avant vanot nos
éducateurs et tout ça c'est vrai que
vous finalement qu il avait raison quoi
que chacun sa chance
entre l'image que tu avais de la
boulangerie est aujourd'hui la réalité
c'est la même chose c'est différent
c'est différent je me rendais pas compte
quand même du travail que que ça ça
demande et le métier de boulanger mais
encore une fois c'est c'est un beau
métier pour moi c'est un beau métier là
je toucher à peu près à tout donc je
produis lepage le qi également tout en
passant par le nettoyage du labo le
l'étiquetage des produits et tout ça et
c'est vrai que c'est super intéressant
qu est ce qu on en apprend tous les
jours quand on t'avait équipiers tu
disais que boulanger c'était mon frère
c'est toujours le cas oui oui toujours
toujours ses plus grands rêves et encore
ce serait de pouvoir ouvrir maintenant
avec l'expérience que je suis en train
d'acquérir une boutique en espagne à
l'étranger nous retrouvons maintenant
rabhi un employé aujourd'hui comblée
avec son cdd
même si le chemin très l'école a parfois
été signés
bonjour ça va savoir si l' on se trouve
dans la boulangerie où vous travaillez
vous est fini tout à l'heure exacte à
13h30 alors vous travaillez comment la
nuit le matin l'après midi l'homme le
matin dès trois heures du matin jusqu'à
adéquat 13 heures ou 10 heures du matin
ou sinon de nuit je commence à 10h je
finis à 4 heures du matin c'est pas trop
dur ça il faut prendre le rythme est ce
que ça a été facile de trouver du
travail après la formation et non pas du
tout parce que j'avais postulé bon chez
intermarché super u et m'avaient dit
qu'ils avaient trouvé la formation
d'autres juste en quoi c'est ça le quai
poser problème si c'est à dire on vous
disait quoi pour eux deux mois de
formation c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
complet c'est pas suffisant pas
suffisant par rapport à ses capés qui se
déroule sur une année ou deux ans pour
pour eux deux mois de formation sait pas
c'est pas suffisant vous avez douté
ouais et pendant huit mois j'ai dû tv ce
que j'ai fini la formation mois de mai
et ensuite du mois de mai jusqu'au mois
de décembre pour trouver un emploi
s'étaient alors c'est quand même
aujourd'hui c'est d'aider la fin des
galères voilà auparavant je faisais des
petits boulots s'était désisté des
points trois semaines un mois puis est
arrivé parce que j'ai 39 ans et je me
suis dit que ford va falloir bettina les
matchs que j'ai pas peur on va pas
traîner comme ça
de gauche à droite jusqu'à 10 km jusqu'à
la retraite je vais l'avoir vraiment un
métier dans les nappes et j'ai eu cette
chance-là puis saisi comment vous voyez
votre avenir vous ravir je me dis dans
un premier temps à prendre un 1er mai
même perfectionne dans le métier et
pourquoi pas ouvrir
boulangerie plus tard
[Musique]
pour
merci au co donner la recette pour
retrouver un emploi c'est le credo de
l'école thierry marx à dijon depuis un
an
bonjour vous avez quitté il ya quelques
mois ici avec la première promotion
d'élèves c'est vrai ben écoute et ils
font pour la plupart en emploi on a 90 %
de retour dans leurs pas pour nos
sessions vous les avez suivi vous les
avez la compagnie ni complètement donc
en fait sur un bilan en fin de formation
et puis on les accompagne vers l'emploi
avec aussi pôle emploi et nous avec
notre réseau de professionnels nous
comment ça se passe vous les appelez oui
où commence à vraiment ça oui oui parce
qu'il ya des personnes qui va en leur
dis faut absolument que vous nous
donniez sont dans l'obligation par
rapport à leurs engagements qui est
signée puisqu'ils sont des formations
entièrement financé donc il doit vous
faire ce suivi est alors de pièces que
vous avez de nouveaux élèves
ah ben oui là c'est déjà la cinquième
session c'est vraiment ya un vrai
potentiel dans ce métier il ya des
offres
au quotidien à pourvoir quand on sort de
l'école on peut dire qu'on est 100%
autonome 100% autonome j'irai peut-être
pas jusque-là non non on a besoin d'être
bien encadré
parce qu'il ya il ya des choses voilà
c'est des métiers où il faut quand même
un minimum d'expérience pour devenir
quand même autonome mais en fonction du
comportement de la volonté de la
motivation je pense qu'on peut le
devenir très vite
déjà présente dans sept villes
françaises une nouvelle école du chef
thierry marx ouvrira bientôt à toulouse